[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
before the livestream started and like I
was on the stage and I desperately
needed to do a dump that was the day
that I realized that every like
clockwork I live in it 11 o'clock I need
to take a massive dump and I haven't
done mine today so there could be a
point today where I find myself on the
stream or I will I mean if that happens
we keep going and we have to keep going
yeah but you all got and smothered
cuz you sit right next to ya you won't
like at least like endure it and you can
deal with it I have to pee I might pee
myself while we're doing this I'll have
to figure out some way of telling each
other we could get like Callie or
someone in here come in and I do like a
pee break
maybe if we wink I'll call you an eight
I'll say yes I'll say you're an eight
and and i'll in your attempt yeah hello
and welcome to I am tomorrow and I'm
Kurt Davina this is amazing yes so we're
gonna be playing some video games
objectively the best video games that
you can play yes these aren't GameSpot's
best video games they are the best two
more and Kurt's amazing video today
we're starting off with which is
actually quite serendipitous because the
first one went on sale today oh it did
yeah yes
we're playing Mac to having guests give
us give us the other one the other
screen the game here we go
- so so I I like neck a lot I do - yeah
it's how you can play am I gonna play
well I mean I would like to play first
if possible I spent a lot of time saying
this up my dude so uh well then why
don't wait to challenge I'll challenge
you have you played slaps don't do
flowers yeah like you know play slaps
so this is a slap right okay oh you must
have played slaps no I slap do this
having at the broader camera so we can
see what is this come on dude okay see
so there one person does this okay and
the other person basically has to know
you know people keep it like this and
then you have to go first
okay first ten and then we'll see who
gets to play neck okay neck - so we'll
do we'll do ten ten attempts and whoever
gets the most out of ten gets to play
neck - first you go you're going down
yeah all right every flex is like like a
like a like an awesome slaps is it
there's a person who goes first
yes I'll go first okay one in the chat
is saying the game has co-op so what
yeah well we only have one controller
yeah we know yeah okay alright so I'm
gonna go go for it go okay okay
mind games baby so now I gotta go no no
no okay fine okay got it got it got it
I've got one so far okay yes okay what
about mind games your hands are shaking
so much right now finger finger
okay okay ready yes reflexes like an
opossum so that's three out of three
you're gonna be playing knack okay
you got to keep you got a touched
fingers okay all right ready
that's four okay and you sneeze do it
[Laughter]
okay clearly these are not my skill
we're gonna go for we went for a high
kick high kick contest you'd probably
win oh why can you kick higher than my
fake I'll go six out of six okay fine
fine well that means you get to play no
okay wait a minute okay with unfilled
noughts and crosses Evan this is you
Evan did you do this you do this did you
leave this here guys I'm just switching
the board over here okay this look you
can't just leave an unfilled noughts and
crosses this looks strategically placed
almost well I guess we have to fill it
in
you can't have an onion crosses so I'm
fine so I owe you one Alaska we agree
that I I start playing that you start
yeah I start playing yes but we have a
chance to come back to this I don't
think so all right let's say if you've
been an awesome cross yes yeah
completely by the way it's called
tic-tac-toe with I'm pretty sure in the
UK is called an awesome concert if
anyone the chat is from the UK let us
know okay it's definitely cool noughts
and crosses evan has n being the chair
confirming that to confirm that but can
we please get back to neck - can you
factor can you look up and then put
yourself on camera tell the tell us if
it's a pull that up real quick just
you look good we caught hey you so know
we don't know what you're saying you've
screwed it up
you've gone silent this is the voice of
God is gone he's back okay you're back
now okay yeah yeah yeah meanwhile we'll
play this looks like this and then you
can and then wish decides wants them for
who gets to play neck okay okay you go
first
unless you wanna flip a coin yeah yeah
if you go Quinn I don't actually have
chapstick yeah gone no wait how I've got
coin I don't have a coin let's hear a
flip in that case okay according to
Wikipedia in American English it's
tic-tac-toe and in British English its
knots and crosses so we're both writing
both front yeah all right so it's not
okay so I I call back I call neck now go
back I call Mac you call neck yeah I
call back then okay all right ready yeah
yeah what I get to go for us in
tic-tac-toe no surpluses okay ready
all right do you know there is a
strategy to always win this do you know
it is it to distract the other person no
no there's like a strategic like if you
put your first move in a certain place
and then your second move in a certain
place you always win isn't it just
creating a role not the rules but like
it's that you can block you create your
like through to specific placements
don't tell me you're straight I don't I
don't know it I'm tracking if you know
it I'm I know it that's that's not fair
then is it go ahead all right cool so am
I in notes or crosses yeah you're not
I kind of want to be across though okay
fine be an ethical sorry I'll be or not
I'm like I'm like real quick yes I do
have two waters because I'm gonna be
here for a while these cups are really
tiny well stay hydrated you drink one
and then your bladder is full and then
hurry on drinking and then you pee into
the other cup yeah it's like uh
unreliable as always
okay okay always gone for the officer
come on
there's if I if you put it here yeah you
had an intent you can get these three
things correct yeah oh yeah that's how
no Sun crosses work okay I know I'm just
telling your shares yo loud yeah
I'm gonna tell you my strategy though it
seems like you've done the exact same
thing as I have on the opposite side
don't turn it around you'd confuse my
strategy by moving the orientation of my
notes and mine crosses so that's weird
alright pre-beck okay
most last time you played this many many
years ago did you lose I'm gonna go well
you can't get that row you've because I
have that uh huh I'm just letting you
know yeah yeah yeah I know I'm dude hey
sure
find out
so just so you all know this is not fair
that's what we're looking at right now
[Laughter]
when I said I know I'm doing I'm telling
you I know what I'm doing okay
pick a square any square
you don't goof me who me he doesn't see
it yeah but he's a lot oh no no no no
you have another chair go ahead okay I
think we can tell I won here look at
that the perfect snakes and lettuce this
one fact snakes and ladders you were
playing tic-tac-toe also you snakes and
ladders isn't that isn't that a candy
candy town of chutes and ladders a candy
- candy town land so does so thus far in
the curtain to Malta [ __ ] Kurtz awesome
game stream I have beaten you slaps
and tic-tacs Nixon letters in a conveyor
and knock him back as well so I have
thoroughly won the
the contests for who gets to play neck
so knack to time baby what's what's that
your shoulders touching right there
guess who
having did you not clean the studio like
we said when was this even last use okay
I mean Evan I think this was I think
that was that hair from like extra life
or something hey we didn't even do extra
life in this room I had it again I don't
know but this looks I well I haven't
played guess who bit nostalgic
attachment oh yeah I'm getting red I
should get to picture it matches my
socks my socks no blue matches your
socks black black look at all right so
just quite a quick game before we get
into yeah okay that's fine we'll get
back to neck - okay okay
how do you play guess who again all
right so I'm like I actually know this
game and I'm very good at this game so
well I've opened the first row and it's
all white people so there's no
representation on this board yes it's
it's how I note my bad Danny open odds
got like a weird fez thing going on he
could be Middle Eastern in some regard
but you'll see down Philip look she's
like a proper Tam in there Who am I in
this board I'm Maria Oh Maria
you do have Maria energy
can we see Maria on the other camp Maria
this is it this is this is who I am not
this nerd the scale Devil's Den Maria I
think I've got Philip like I probably
look most like Philip which is a sad sad
thing to say okay so so how do you play
this game okay so we have the pic I ran
a person from this deck of cards okay
I can't know who it is all right ooh
maybe we should show it to the audience
why so here here pick one and then all
I'll close my eyes now look the other
way because there's literally a giant TV
with us on in there silly camera oh I
don't think the camera concise
upside-down that's why my bad it's
really small so I'm gonna walk up to the
camera
no okay okay you're good you're good
you're good okay now I have to pick one
mm-hmm where's your card no well my hand
okay I'm gonna pick this one cuz re on
the table here okay now you have to
close your eyes we have a message in
chat would you like me to read it yeah
going what do they want
they said it's from Gibran Haider he
says damn I'm so happy to see Kurt in
GameSpot I started watching his channel
when he used to play Skyrim on switch
Wow
this is a game stream not Kisker stream
line Lex hold on wait Tim look you've
been winning this entire stream I can
have a moment of glory
Jim Brom bridge on Jim Braun hater
Gibran Singh the eyes I would have been
jabroni hey approach well nonetheless
Gibran I have a deep deep appreciation
for you thank you for being here thank
you for enduring in this and thank you
for joining me in two more for our
amazing game stream do you need that do
you need okay okay I have to show the
card anyways thank you thank you
anyways furthermore Tam's great too you
should look at him okay this is you
don't bother
it's our focus they won't see it I'm not
looking
keep those eyes closed and Bob Jones
1980 says he likes both of you guys
equally statement
are you doing wise now I'm opening my
eyes I'm alright Bob Jones 1980s says he
likes both of you guys equally Wow you
already say that once yeah but we have a
lot of nobody responded okay I have my
guy okay so now the audience knows we'll
get back to neck in a sec by the way
yeah I mean this is once we once we
accomplish this this is how we decide
who is the plays neck who plays neck
okay and who plays with what controls
and we how would we do it
okay um since you're the winning boy of
the stream you can go first so how do we
play so I have to ask questions yeah
yeah so singular yes so much okay so
it's like does your person look like a
dweeb a hub a herb yeah does your person
have okay okay listen does your person
is your person you can't see is your
person does your person does your person
does your person have a mustache
No and then you knock and then you
eliminate I have a mustache you don't
have a mustache you don't have mustache
you don't have mustache oh you you you
mm not you just got weird been genka
says you were both very sweet boys
no no thank you been Thank You Ben Thank
You Ben
I really hope you're enjoying the one
question that eliminated almost everyone
that's not entirely true
okay okay fine
[Music]
does your person have a dimple chin
yes they like so like the line the
dimple like that Oh dimple chin like
uh-uh no no no no no what do you
consider a dimple chin so they don't
have a dimple chin no no no okay
I mean I'm talking like there's like
there's no crease nothing there's no
crease okay okay okay does your person
have black hair
No
don't your person have black hair no so
I have to remove everyone with black
hair sorry is your person
weapons if you guess and you get wrong
do we just carry loose that sucks if I
mean if you go out and you go on a limb
and try to guess like if without you
know not having a single definite person
and it's wrong it's already loose okay
okay
is it a man
yes
I'm so excited to play knack to
this is missing of one
oh wait okay go ahead okay
does your person have here
yes
head to the Belgravia Center Richard
does your does your person
have facial hair
no they don't officially know
damn it's getting close is your person
blonde
you
No
I have to go hold on hold on you go I
take a gift now don't you does your
person look like Rodney Dangerfield I
don't know who Rodney Dangerfield is
Evan can you pull the picture of Rodney
Dangerfield please
who is Rodney Dangerfield I know Rodney
Trotter no no Evan are you continually
Plus sorry I'm here what would you like
can you pull up a picture of Rodney
Dangerfield on your phone and show us
yeah hold on just one sec do anything
for you hurt thank you do you mind
explaining to the audience what you guys
are doing right now we're gonna play
knack - we're gonna play knack to you we
both really like knack - so we have to
decide who's gonna flip our plane back -
so we're going I mean and there's just
there's a lot of I technically should
have done this you're not winning beat
us slaps and then I beat you at North's
and crosses and knack and back
I'm knock him back each do you see this
this doesn't look like a game one that
was one you had no - I had two options -
me and both of them would have won you
keep protesting on my victories you deny
me my victories you oppress me my
victories you still deprive me of my
victory you can play like modern society
you can play an act - and not stop well
we've already come to that we've we've
just
[Music]
Evan Ronny Dangerfield I'm just yes no
really what no all right that's the
generic old white dude that's Ronnie
Dangerfield that looks like four
different you don't know Ronnie go back
to school no in the Army now no British
yeah he's England Caddyshack yeah I know
Caddyshack funny remembering so that you
have like him that your wrist buries you
made the wrong move there so I had one
left so I had a guaranteed almost
victory here I can s I've screwed up the
kind of letting you mass process show me
I've got a guaranteed victory
tell me who you have in your scenario
you should have guessed instead of
wasted a question is your personality oh
[ __ ]
how this happened
Matt Paget's very disappointing utan for
not knowing who Roger Dangerfield is no
I don't know how this happened
game this game sucks now I run back Oh
I've beaten you in three different game
I said I just game this floor you got it
wrong we need who who made this game um
guess who made the game guess you know
is it Hasbro I mean in China China made
it makes perfect sense as bro is it
house bro Hasbro specifically Australia
only there's also a New Zealand branch
this needs to be patched so blame the
keys yeah there's this baby immediately
this has been patched there's been many
versions that have come out since this
one I did specifically have this is the
resurrection notes up for guess series
version so this is probably this is okay
this is V 1.0 so there's probably like
we're up to probably be 3.4 by now how
did that go wrong you lost but I've
beaten you in four different games
you've known me slaps North's and
crosses
was the other one that was it alright -
then you ugly
oh and knocking back three those I'm in
a game that's the decision-maker you
said earlier that be you in that so
three so you need to be me in two more
games first I need to be tuned one more
now you've neck and back is taken off
you slaps and okay process I want to run
back on this cuz something's wrong no
one play test guess who properly this is
not funny because you lost yeah because
you guessed wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah
alright one more run back then we play
Mac cuz you have you know why would
somebody following me that's funny
choose your choose your destiny so your
fate will be sealed okay I'm not gonna
show the audience deceiver I'm just
gonna keep it to myself actually pull
one down make sure no one's calling me
like you said okay you'll be really
exciting right now some knack to
gameplay it we're getting there
get that one okay check it out a victory
Evan are you you are you not enjoying
this I would enjoy neck to a whole lot
more I'll say here Evan
yes Kurt
what can I do for you today
let us flourish let us yeah let us be
the PIPA the the game the amazing game
people we were always we've got ten
games that we're gonna go through we'll
get there in ten and and thirty minutes
times yeah we have easy and yeah we can
get to knack to in that time I'll be
fine
well I expect a written guess who review
on GameSpot calm there's already one
there well we need to do the patch notes
yeah yeah okay all right also you can
put your card here so you know why would
I do that so it's just like it's cooler
if you hold it up okay cuz I'm not gonna
show the only this real quick and you
didn't look so it's fine I showed it
earlier yeah I see it
okay cool okay I won last time all right
man I and I even won going on like I
took some risks dimple chin Rodney
Dangerfield you don't even know who that
is don't know who that is
okay go on does your person have
a hat
what define hat are they wearing a hat
yes there is there's a piece of clothing
on their head like a hat like it's not
hair it's a hat like if I were to wear
if I were like if I were you went to
France and said ha ha they would ask you
what kind of this is a has Berets
different those are hats no no in France
like you guys there is their fashionable
item on their on their head that isn't
naturally growing out of them I wouldn't
describe this as fashionable is it I
dunno if it's fashionable oh no but it's
not hair and it's not skin there's
something covering those two things
correct yeah then that's a hat I feel
like you're playing real fast and loose
with the definition of hat and a lot of
people who I don't know exist in the
fashion sphere would look at this
okay okay is your person male define
male let's not do this okay fine
yes damn our single ladies
and these most of these ladies look like
they were in committed relationships to
refer except for one of them looks a bit
all right cool
okay
is your person
a woman
yes
damn
I can smell nap too already oh man look
at that it's its knack to pause on the
screen you can play it right now we have
to the games almost over so we're almost
there okay okay okay okay we'll be
waiting for you now compromise does your
person have hair
yes [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay as your person wearing glasses
yes all right
is your person
Bernard
No damn I took a risk is your person I
declare that I am guessing your person
it's Claire yuria show it show it right
there right there who did you have I
[ __ ] one-eyed David damn I knew was
David you didn't know it's David you
says Bernard all right fine you beat me
twice uh guess who the most broken and
unbalanced or bored xa1 twice at it
can't be bet busted play the damn game
well then we're going great yeah I mean
I guess so yeah absolutely I mean
actually playing by the way I know
you've beaten me in what I beat you in
are we've really counting nakid it twice
you you added and I come back to it so
you can't take that was that a deck of
cards you okay well fine since we're
let's let's call it a square right and
we'll play we just play a card games we
can do with cards right so we have to
say that we have a card game now yeah
because I'm not I'm not satisfied with
with me not choosing knack first because
I beat you twice we're technically high
three time no we tagged it's technically
tied I mean what do you count neck and
back as a game as a bear in mind I did
it initially and Kurt I did knock him
back to it you can you can watch the VOD
you can watch the playback of it I
guarantee it swear on my mom's life it's
you added it because I was saying two
slaps and snakes and ladders and then
you were like I knock him back and I
went and not come back this is just just
perfectly sitting over there in the
shelf and there Deadly Premonition
themed
yeah
for those of you who don't know okay
objectively the best game ever made okay
what game are we playing
you know knack - is co-op I'd like to
reiterate we don't have a second
controller Evan do you know how much
things supposed to do this is we do you
think what is made of money what do we
have madcatz if we have a Mad Catz
controller you can go on by one like $20
yeah we are barely getting paid in this
job we cannot afford a single another
controller we are shared this controller
between 30 people on games well and then
we had to buy an AK - and then we had to
buy an AK - which is still very
expensive
except for nak one if anything an
indicator of its enduring quality
exactly yeah
so this tells you how good one
controller we are Sony for another
controller for free and they were like
we don't do handouts yeah like which is
ridiculous
they launched in a new console and can't
even give away the stuff that's attached
to the old crap how do we do ridiculous
what game are we playing I'm very good
at this he played jump a snap let me
play snap isn't that the do you see what
I just did there
no do again do again you can you play
solitaire I didn't have to place all day
I love solitaire I don't know I said I
met Francis York Morgan on the card I
think in another life I would have been
a magician but I'm glad about this one
you see that no I missed it again
here alright you've done it enough times
now we get it wait now you know how to
shuffle the cards yeah
are we gonna call honey we are
apparently I'm calling from who's that
Oh Peter Brown
oh it's Peter Brown hey what's up can
you mute can you stop fighting so much
well I I beat her three times a game so
we be in my slaps then I be in here
what you're driving here where are you
you're not even here for the stream well
how can you tell me what are you late
what we're doing just fine
tam-tam and I are getting along I'd be
in three times you called us
hey you you interrupted our this is our
stream same boy Oh Peter settle the
score is neck or back a game or not very
much so like we were trying to do a coin
toss this is coin so this is a comeback
right you look you flip the case and
it's not that's not a game but it's a
form of chance
so I initially said I beat him at slaps
and then noughts and crosses and then he
said unprompted
and nakon back did you drink out of this
so this feels empty
no so he added napkin back to it and
then after losing two consecutive games
he decided knock him back was no longer
a game having added it himself
is that not unfair okay what hold on
Peter before you answer you just need to
objected clear whether it's a game in
the first place or not because my
opinion is objective but we need it we
need an out-and-out faced twice smart
man your review you reviewed things you
tell me is Nagre back a game I can see
this not game but you added it as a get
him speak
what my god yeah yes it's a new game
from Bach Sony apparently from hat from
Hasbro New Zealand
yeah that checks out okay what yes yes
see Thank You P uh well signing that for
us so what are we going best out of
three or no no best out for them
apparently all right Peter what are you
doing right now why are you why are you
here
I'm in the midst of doing what I do one
second wow you've got a warehouse yes
I'm not gonna dami you're calm
everybody's okay all right thanks dad
thank you love you too computer yo can't
believe you just did that to us see you
having a favorite member I'm are we
doing snap yes to desire ways yes yes
okay so we're going best out of four
that's not force now can take a really
long time
let's go no best out of four for like
all the cow okay place not know I don't
know how to place now did you shuffle
that yes you what you want me to do it
again no you do it
you shuffle it ah you need a lot of
things you think you've brought some so
especially Billie just cuz you can I
practiced because I'm bad at things and
I wanted to be good at something you saw
how good I was a good crisp easy feeling
ready okay do I hit you No
are we playing suits or numbers you
decide let's chat decide suits a number
yeah what does Chad say suits or numbers
I'll let you know when those come in
does anybody watching yeah we got we've
got Bob Jones we got Bob Jones thanks
for watching Tom Jones there we go okay
you cannot look at your cards has anyone
said suits or numbers yet nobody yet
suits or numbers I'm gonna wait for Chet
Ben says wait is this go fish it's
called snap and I want you know one no
suits or numbers
so
this works is don't look at my cards
yeah don't look your card yeah you
picked a card from the top and you lay
it down okay you can't do it slowly so
you give the system first you have to
put it down and depending on the suit or
the number if I put down a three and you
put down a three on top you have to
place your hand over it and say snap
okay those two suits we got we got two
four suits okay let's do so then if you
do that before I put my hand on it you
take those cards
whoever has all the cards so the number
or this in this case the suits have to
match yeah so if you put down diamond
and diamond snap okay okay so what if
you like I put out diamond and then you
put down diamond okay I get it I get it
I get it I get it I get okay who's gonna
first you go first oh okay I win these
are my cards now okay it's stuck to my K
ready can you guys call out the cards
okay okay that was a I got two we got
two diamonds there okay
so we have is that spades hearts hearts
huh yeah I'm not good at these like I'm
good at these the ones where it's called
words guess who go they stick to my
hands sweat your hands it's not weight
those hearts damn you sure those Seca's
sit okay damn damn damn
no you're Dini the steam machine
unsportsmanlike know either mind I put
mine back
I mean you should technically shuffle
them
you should shuffle your cards you should
shuffle them and then fold them back
into yours
yeah this is so stressful especially cuz
it's good you know yeah okay
alrighty I hurt my hand all right ooh
Dimond am I now I just I just saw
Elizabeth oh just like
you've moved the stuff I'm bad at the
snap part okay
hearts okay okay ready
daddy first some knack - I'm ready for
having a minute one minute evident
woman--it when Eddie done
we need yeah we're nearly there
diamond 10 of diamonds 10 of diamonds
you you want longer arms than me all
right you're not pushing me out of
Center okay okay go you don't need to
put that much effort ball off table you
don't need to put that much effort
okay okay okay okay clubs club club a
space
damn they say no I am bad you can see
the of another street stealing from
people this is a this is the difference
between a Tekken fighter
yeah and me or street fighter yeah
fighter and me okay
okay there you go
I'm being fair moving it so you've got
Captain Marvel and closed
yes it's not son of a but okay okay
spades
wait
oh okay rewind it every oven have I been
saying snap or not you've been watching
this no yes okay like one time I you
lying you're lying Levin who gets this
I've been screaming snap asserting my
snap dominance every single time you
haven't been saying [ __ ] he's rarely
want any college how can he be saying a
few times maybe faster than him yeah
beyblade rules you gotta yell snap it
down oh yeah okay okay I'm gonna do the
right thing how we fall and we gave you
those cars let's flip I mean I'm willing
to concede I'm well I still have a state
I think when people go when people go
back and watch the archive of this they
will see I've been snapping like I
didn't know that was a necessity I've
given you two cars I've given you two
cars no I'm taking two cards and then
we've got one card in the middle in the
pile all right ready it's clubs
yeah yeah I said that though okay you
also your hand is lingering and I don't
like that that's against the road I put
it down and move away you can't be like
okay fine fine fine okay
let's keep going let's keep going yes
and just like waiting okay all right
watch okay you stop my hands really hard
then it kind of seems like whoever puts
the card down last has an advantage
because their hand yes Snap is their
perfectly balanced game because the
other person gets to play teto this I
have we had patch notes
no but you get the other person gets to
observe so the other pose they're still
a the person point they turn Tim like
your hand was already pretty close when
you went and snapped it no I moved it
back no Evan I agree with you I moved it
back I don't I don't believe that this
is perfectly okay
you
hand back yes it's right here what's he
paying you a compliment thank you
you know we just did it was okay
either that's like hmm the tables are
turning the snaps are happening can't we
just get all this back to play oh yeah
okay yeah we still have to play neck
right we're right okay
oh sorry move it babe hi his cards are
real slippery
yeah and it's sticky Oh
everyone Karla by the way you've got
that pole I shuffle it you got a shuttle
of earlier that was good
okay when do we know who's one when all
the cards are on one person inside okay
ready
spade hand back its back it's not mine
it's mine your hand is way over there -
wait look where my hand is and look my
limbs are longer what do you want okay
pods and windowing here buddy
I was real close
spade
diamond
club hearts spade diamond-hard saw
you know who wears a lot of suit snack
because he can transform we're almost
there or what's once we know who is the
winner of this game is anybody in chat
really complaining
I think people just move use okay but
alright heart
I feel like that's the best distance
okay these two lines okay okay
hearts clubs Spade diamond
club hearts bait Thailand
sorry I hesitate I did hesitate I don't
know why I did that I apologize move
back a bit
Oh diamonds
aids did you shuffle that oh yeah hey oh
yeah Club ha ha
speed I need shuffle this this is what
okay but it isn't neck hold on give us
two seconds
this is we'll get through this we've got
the top ten because the moment we start
playing it people are gonna be like it's
like it's gonna be that like ah yeah
like the the the the triumphant moment
yes we'll get to knack and then nine on
the game's spades spades diamonds look
at this what look at look at my
achievements look at this dude come on
we've gotta get to Mac I know we're
almost there yeah except for the fact
that this babe I might be actually
playing neck okay okay we're gonna do
speed snap okay ready okay so you have
to just put it down one off the other
know if you put one down on you someone
else put your coffee it has to go mmm
okay how many cards you have left a lot
hot club
okay okay we should say say the suit as
well okay okay ready spray babe hey your
hand was not back here oh okay
this is let's do just a few more cards
and then we'll get the knack okay okay
okay okay okay okay yes go hearts quit
spade diamonds it's hockey
just play snap forget this yes now okay
okay go
all right we're gonna do five five okay
most cards wins okay go go oh fudge
you
I don't know why I do that oh sorry hate
it's a snap I did fix not bad he did say
snap I'll actually stick up for Tam I
can't even tell what's happening count
the cards who's gone most cards yes to
play neck bracelet yeah there we are
I haven't how you doing in there how's
your cups of water I just give us an
inside luck we really wanna Signac give
us say give us an inside look at what
it's like in there right now
I still we can't hear we're gonna count
the cause and then then you gotta count
on what I'm putting down sixteen
seventeen one oh three four five six
seven eight one two ten eleven
twenty-eight twenty-nine now it's very
obvious that I be the wall knows that
I'd be you a snap objectively the most
balanced on best game
it's all yours yeah knack is all yours
okay go ahead
here oh my some mac me plain I am so
excited some neck game finally made it
wait go to the options because how do
you play do you do inverted camera
cuz I'm not gonna play it doesn't really
give me options - it's not really what
yeah but your frames per second
oh yeah what no it's Q you want no no
disable it you want to say but I want it
I want it capped I want the framerate so
over instead of the dividuals no no no
wait that doesn't disable it because
like you you you get to experience good
things like I'm not a consistency over
the consistency leg I mean but like
don't I have to play it like this is
from a playing experience you want the
locked framerate so there's no issues
with the performance yeah but that's
overrated it's like it's okay if there's
a little hiccups as long as like the the
neck pieces are coming together like
it's a kind of like slow motion it looks
good like when you like wouldn't you
please Sonic is a kid and you like you
get hit by a lot of things in the frame
rate slows down it's almost like it
makes a little bit more dramatic like
slow motion we have to play like not
watch Mac we're playing neck and we're
experiencing it yeah if we're playing
neck we need to pick the option that
makes it most fun to play not most fun
to look at what was the default what's
the deep what does the game want us to
do well by default it's disabled well
then that's how it should be played give
you an option we're playing this on a
ps4 pro yeah but they wouldn't put the
option in there for people it's for it's
for the less powerful inferior versions
of the system there are no inferior
versions of Mac to go ahead oh please I
don't want to play if you're gonna be
upset the entire time we have to figure
out somewhere residing on or off
disabled we're back
we've done that go back and give we've
got you've got to come up with some way
of us doing something today I'm not
budging
well disabled I don't think that's fair
I will be very long exactly you want all
the games you get to play first the
least I using these experiences the way
I want I just want to see just disable
it I'm not gonna be upset if you enable
it yeah pictionary pictionary we don't
even have anything for pictionary we got
we got papers okay friends by we do
picture to decide whether frame rate is
on frames per second okay on or off I'm
gonna go first though so what is the
rule I'm gonna think of a something of a
movie and I'm not gonna use any writing
I'm only to use pictures okay and I have
to guess the movie and I have to unlike
I need a timer of some kind okay I can
get a timer Adhan time us 30 seconds
let's make this quick so then we can get
to playing neck
hold on I'm gonna start a timer for 0
minutes and 30 seconds all right I'm
gonna do this down here so we can get a
clear view you're gonna pick a movie I
have to guess the movie yeah and you
have to guess the movie exactly get the
north's and crosses my victorious
noughts and crosses off to off the table
so isn't embarrassing you already okay
keep guessing and start guessing boy is
ah is that turbo man one movie jingle
all the way
ten seconds to spare - that's he got you
all the way you got Jude all the way
from this damn boy wow I need to like
get into detail and draw sweet muscles
or his tabs I think all right fine you
can play it enabled since what you won
fair and square
you guessed you all the way
I just want to bomb and all wow I'm good
at this game baby
except for guess who damn I've beaten
you four games he's still given in the
big gun all right go ahead
alright this is the fall
cuz you keep moving around so music ten
SFX
ten voice ten HD are disabled you can't
turn that up any louder brightness no
Frank's a second enabled 30 frames per
second capped high frame rate I was a
high frame rod we didn't have to have
that argument at all guys 11:59 oh well
here stop playing that obviously neck
one of the greatest games of all time
ps4 launched hi or an incredible
showcase or sequel to the PSP yeah the
story a sequel to a people on trial and
incredible game co-op really fun by Mark
Sony I mean it's it's what brought us
together and this is waste wine yes
wanna stream lines together and yeah
it's an exciting games play it's like
people definitely clown on it absolutely
I think that it's incredibly underrated
I think that's a part of its I think
that's a part of its legacy yeah and
knowing that under
the clowning underneath the fun that
people are having with it not making of
it it's a genuine true experience at its
core yeah it did get a sequel after all
so let's get into it a new game okay
empty slot thank you for joining us for
this incredible Tom Tom and Kurt's
amazing game stream we played what we
agreed to be the best games yes
it's throwing with knack knack and we'll
see you you can find me on twitter i'm
at small age and I am at curt underscore
in Davina let us know what you think of
nack and we'll see you again next week
yeah have you um okay I think I didn't
smell it no I've been strategically
moving my ass oh wow well I I mean I
know yeah I need you all right I'm not
definitely little just a little